-Ah to be the number one hero is a bore.
I'm going to take some time off.
Austin Reaves...come amuse me.
-Things haven't been the same
since the mandatory minutes rule.
-You there, you better not be resting!
-We’re finally all together-
but we couldn’t feel further apart.
-Initiate trash talk sequence:
you missed the bucket, Westbrook.
-Disrespect my family name again and I'll unplug your a-
-We’re not resting, I swear.
No, I still have a few good years left!
What the...?
-It’s Joker vs. Luka in Match 1.
-[Chuckle].
-You monster! Now my homeland expects me a to win a title.
Step back!
-If they keep adding tournament, I will keep winning tournament.
-It can’t be.
-Oh, and Scoot continues to not play like Dame.
-Mitchell with the jab! Haliburton drives!
-The Golden State elders look lost in the Thunder cloud.
-Steph, attack!
-Whose team do you think this is?
-Yo, ya'll the old men from the commercials!
-You ain't never seen a joey this tall, eh mate?
-What’s up fam? It's an honor for you to play with me.
-Oh, and Brunson looks alone out there!
-So do you want to attack?
-No man, you can attack first.
-Are you sure? I can-
-No, you go.
-Teamwork...must be nice...
-And the first rounds of the knockout stages are well underway
in the IN-SEASON TOURNAMENT!
-The In-Season Tournament?
-Computing new information.
-F**k yeah, a fight!
♪♪♪ [Theme Song] ♪♪♪
-Remember: the winner of the In-Season Tournament
will receive cash prizes.
-Board man does get paid.
-Pay me in revenge!
-Future Inglewood vs. The Dallas Plains...commence battle!
-A hero tournament.
Time to remind everyone about Playoff P.
-Classic.
-Another rough start for the Clippers.
-Yikes, and they think we're dysfunctional.
-C'mon, Kyrie.
-Dysfunctional? Man, why is everyone always talking shit about us?
-Idea! We wait till later.
-No! We go all out,
put up huge stats,
then run out of gas for the rest of the year.
-You’ve got to take this regular season stuff seriously!
-Man, Playoff P doesn't work.
It's just you but you glow a little.
-Incorrect. This is different?
-The Clippers prepare for the Rockets.
-Yeah, I'm the best ever.
-Oh, Playoff P. I'm so scared.
I'm not really scared, by the way.
-I've learned to take the regular season
as seriously as playoff mountain.
I'm now...
In-Season Tournament P.
-What?!
-Bionic Kick.
-I refuse to believe I brought this on myself.
-Now we enjoy the low stakes of in-season fighting.
-Jokic throws….but George intercepts!
-This is for the bubble!
-Westbrook looking like his old self!
-Triple Double!
-Russ passes to…Russ?! And oh my god, Russ takes it home!
-Activate: The Klaw.
- Oh my, the crowd goes wild
for the first defensive move of the entire tournament!
-Wa ha ha ha. This is fun.
-And I can’t believe it. Even the Traveller is here…
for now.
-Perfect.
This tournament is just one more boost
in my resume against..
him.